raha sei ein sehr aktives Kind mein
faribaba rizard als Englischlehrerin sei
Online-Unterricht während corona-zeiten
unmöglich gewesen rahar hätte ihr keine
Ruhe gelassen
Fariba musste umsatteln notgedrungen
verkauft jetzt Schmuck und
Haushaltswaren in ihrem instagram-shop
alles macht sie selbst Licht Fotos
Angebote online stellen dann wartet sie
auf Kunden in diesen Tagen muss sie sehr
lange warten
[Musik]
die Leute brauchen solche Sachen wie
Schmuck und sowas heute nicht so
dringend deshalb kaufen Sie nichts und
als dann das Internet blockiert wurde
kam mein Geschäft zum Stillstand das hat
mich wirklich sehr bedrückt und traurig
gemacht arbeiten
[Musik]
sie hatten von einem guten Leben
geträumt sie und ihr Mann der ist die
ganze Woche im Land unterwegs fariber
muss allein zurechtkommen verdient
gerade mal 60 Euro im Monat mit beiden
Gehältern kommen sie auf rund 250 das
reicht hinten und vorne nicht
mein einziges Einkommen habe ich durch
dieses Online-Geschäft an dem einen Tag
verdiene ich mal was dann zwei Tage
nichts und manchmal verkaufe ich eine
ganze Woche nichts
gegen die Regierung auf die Straße zu
gehen traut sie sich nicht bei unserem
Interview aber trägt sie bewusst kein
Kopftuch sie gehört zur großen Mehrheit
die die Faust in der Tasche bald und
sonst ums tägliche Brot kämpft sowie
auch Weser soll ich hier er beliefert
Lebensmittelgeschäfte und Supermärkte
mit Hühnereiern das sei krisenfest
dachte er weit gefehlt seit der vor
sieben Monaten damit anfing hat sich der
Einkaufspreis fast verdoppelt
die Regierung hat die
futtermittelzuschüsse gestrichen jetzt
müssen die Bauern Hühnerfutter im
Ausland einkaufen und weil der
Dollarkurs so stark gestiegen ist haben
die Produzenten Probleme bekommen damit
sind auch meine Ausgaben
gestiegenhändler wie saalehi oder
Ladenbesitzer wie Ali alle haben weniger
Einnahmen und die Protestwelle die das
Land der fast hat macht die Lage noch
kompliziert
Streiks aufgerufen wurde sind die Leute
aus Protest zu Hause geblieben niemand
hat eingekauft ich weiß nicht mehr wie
ich meine Miete Strom und Wasser
bezahlen soll
sie alle seien Opfer einer fatalen
Entwicklung in Iran meint der bekannte
Wirtschaftsjournalist said Laylas denn
trotz Sanktionen sei die iranische
Wirtschaft gewachsen was allerdings vor
allem die Reichen noch reicher und die
Armen ärmer gemacht habe wir haben wir
haben immer mehr arme Menschen
mittlerweile leben 25 bis zu 30
Millionen Menschen unter der
Armutsgrenze
die Unruhen belasten die iranische
Wirtschaft zusätzlich aus Protest werden
Regime Banken und Betriebe boykottiert
viele davon sind im Besitz der
Revolution Garden die haben in den
vergangenen Jahren gut verdient wenn das
Regime die Proteste nun mit aller Härte
bekämpft geht es um die Verteidigung der
Islamischen Republik und damit vor allem
ums eigene Geschäft
das ist Plünderei nicht einfach nur
Korruption das kann man sich nicht
vorstellen aber zwischen 20 und 25
Milliarden US-Dollar wurden aus der
Landes geschafft als Kapitaltransfers
nach Kanada oder in andere westliche
Staaten
während die mächtigen ihr Geld um den
Globus schicken müssen mittelständische
Unternehmen versuchen zu überleben wie
der metallbetriebnahme hier nennt man
Korruption und Missmanagement freundlich
volkswirtschaftliche Probleme
unsere Probleme sind enorm und sie haben
ihre Ursache in unserer Volkswirtschaft
wenn sich die Volkswirtschaft verbessern
würde profitierten alle Industriezweige
und jeder würde sein Stück vom Kuchen
abbekommen
wir dürfen die Fabrik von nach Besuchen
in schalouse vier Autostunden von Tehran
entfernt es ist das erste Mal seit
Beginn der Proteste im September dass
uns die Behörden erlauben die Hauptstadt
zu verlassen auch hier ein Charlus hatte
es Proteste gegeben doch wie in Teheran
wollen uns die Behörden offenbar zeigen
dass sie die Lage wieder unter Kontrolle
haben
im Werk von Napp sagt man uns hier aber
natürlich niemand protestiert
Geschäftsführer man zum Mohammadi führt
uns durch sein Reich Ersatzteile für die
deutschen Maschinen gibt es wegen der
Sanktionen nicht mehr dafür sind
Lieferanten aus anderen Diktaturen wie
Russland oder China eingesprungen die
Scheren sich kaum um die Sanktionen
anders als die meisten Kunden
auch in Indien haben wir Kunden aber die
kamen und sagten wir können euch kein
Geld mehr überweisen stattdessen können
wir euch schwarzen Stoff für eure chados
oder Reis geben
not macht erfinderisch na reagiert er
auf die Sanktionen erschlossen neue
Märkte in Asien und dem Mittleren Osten
und wuchs trotz aller Probleme doch die
Protestwelle ist Ausdruck einer
Unzufriedenheit im Land verstärkt durch
die hohe Inflation Mann zur Mohammadi
sehnt sich nach Normalität
wir wollen dass sich unsere Nationen und
unsere Regierung dass sich alle
zusammensetzen Fehler müssen korrigiert
werden und die Probleme zwischen uns
müssen gelöst werden damit der Druck von
uns genommen wird
online-händlerin farib will nicht auf
ein solches Wunder war die Preise
steigen nicht aber ihr Einkommen für
sich und Ihre Familie sieht sie in Iran
keine Zukunft mehr
ich habe beschlossen dass ich auswandern
werde ich will in ein anderes Land aber
noch weiß ich nicht genau wohin weil die
Situation für Migranten im Moment so
hart ist
sie will gehen für die Zukunft ihrer
Tochter um sie herum sieht sie wie
Unzufriedenheit und Wut mit jedem Tag
wachsen
[Musik]